[Music]
huh it's uture couldn't get me in
trouble that day something could hear me
I wish someone wanted to hear me other
than you I know I'm not supposed to love
music no music no music but my
great-grandma Coco's father was the
greatest musician of all time even esto
de la Cruz one day he left with his
guitar and never returned
my family thinks music is accursed great
great grandfather none of them
understand me I'm supposed to play music
alright this is you're really out there
agents at the Department of family
reunions are available to assist you on
the lookout for a living boy again you
hear when your family
I know your grandpa I'll get you to him
no skeletons don't walk like that house
you walk no I don't there's no one left
in the living world who remembers you
you disappear from this world but you
can change that we gotta find my freak
your grandpa you've gotta do it by
Sunrise what happens at sunrise you'll
be stuck your friend Brad I'm a big fan
never forget how much your family loves
you it's almost sunrise one cannot deny
who one is meant to be
[Music]
but it doesn't have any hair and I don't
have a nose here we are
[Music]